hello everyone
Aya and I will present to you skin
microbiome Solutions based on psoriasis
studies
what is the problem with psoriasis
obserizes The Chronic inflammatory skin
disease it affects 125 million people
worldwide of any age gender or race it
has unknown causes has no cure the
regime ministerial and error and it is a
difficult disease to manage so how can
we get a clearer picture of what is
happening to these patients
skin microbiometer genomics
now the microbial population in
psoriasis patients provides produces
inflammatory molecules and it virus the
body side so it is important to study
the individual microbial profile to
understand their disease condition and
severity
now personalized treatment based on an
individual's microbial profile will
offer the solutions that improve patient
symptoms lower the risk to develop
psoriatic arthritis and reduce their
economic burden
we studied the microbiome of the
psoriasis dataset that is available
under this accession number and we
compared the healthy control group with
absoriasis group and what we found was
that a certain kind of
microbial profile would emerge we saw
that certain species were evident in
both groups other species are more
abundantly one or the other group or
just one group belongs to one
one species only to one group or only on
the other
so that led us to a few conclusions uh
primarily that the skin of terrorized
patients either has a more abundant
pathogenic microbes less conventional
microbes and that each body side has a
different microbial profile
and that leads us to a solution that
would be a probiotic cream that is based
on bacteriotherapy
now we also know that this is requires
long-term management
so therefore for this solution that
would help the patients monitor through
through a monitoring app to
um to include their skin microbiome
profile and learn more through that
now how would it work we take a sample
of the skin microbiome
we provide them with the psorized
microbiome profile and depending on the
skin side the patient receives a
consultation with their dermatologist to
find the correct probiotic cream that
fits there's profile and skin side and
then they use the app to monitor the
development of the treatment
why probability bacterial therapy creams
well firstly our goal is to create a set
of probiotic creams that would be
customized to the skin microbiome of the
skin sides of each patient now
we know that there are studies that show
that the microbes can increase the
immune response or decrease the
abundance of pathogenic microbes so
there's active research on bacterial
therapy right now and we're learning
more how this will work on patients but
also it is a customized solution to a
patient it can be used complementary to
anti-inflammatory treatment of steroids
if it's not invasive and not painful
in terms of a mobile application there
are two types of applications right now
for psoriasis patients one is networking
out which is connecting with people who
have the same issue
and then we have a monitoring Edge we
focus on monitoring apps
because
um we can track the skin area we can
take notes about uh the flare and
duration and severity and the patients
can also connect with their doctor to do
their data and to this we can add now
the skin microbiome profile which can be
potentially also machine learning
technology
um provide them with the updated
research that is specifically related to
the microbiome profile and the
customized list of products that are
known to work on their profile So
eventually
we have a big picture and we can also
add the gut microbiome
as more research finds evidence on skin
gut microbiome axis now
what what the planet looks like ahead is
first to find those skin microbiome
profiles of psoriasis patients on the
literature I collaborate with
dermatologist to identify patients who
have who belong to these profiles create
a timeline for the app development and
to identify the probiotic formulas that
we need for these profiles collaborate
with Pharmaceuticals to produce the
creams and start the app development and
also partner with dermatologists to
start doing trials eventually launch
beta versions and have a valuable
minimum product to invest to pitch to
investors
thank you for your time and have a great
day hit